with its unique art style over-the-top
violence and dark gritty humor
Borderlands is a title that is
unapologetically created its own genre
within the gaming world Borderlands 3 is
set to be released in September 2019 so
whether you need a refresher or this
will be the first game that we played in
the series in this video I'll be summing
up the borderlands story as it's
happened so far
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this all starts off with an advanced
ancient alien race called the yridians
who decided to hide the technology
around the universe behind these lot
structures called vaults and then they
just kind of died out for some reason
zoom forward to the present gameday this
advanced alien technology is hugely
valuable and every large weapons
manufacturers fighting to get their
hands on it
rumors of a vault on the planet Pandora
bring one of the largest munitions
companies Atlas to colonize the world
what they weren't aware of was the fact
that they'd arrived on pandora during
one of its long seven earth year winters
and when the planet started to warm up a
number of creatures started to come out
of hibernation and attack in settlements
completely unprepared for this Atlas
flea Pandora but rival mega corporation
doll ends up taking their place dile
ships in a load of convicts as labor to
start mining the planet for materials
well a dr. Patricia Tannis heads the
team to search for the vault eventually
the vault is found but atlas learns of
us and sins in their private military
force called the Crimson Lance to claim
the vault for themselves
now it's dolls turn to flee Pandora they
pack up everyone and thing but value but
before they leave in a total
in-your-face Atlas they release all of
the convicts into the wild to do
whatever they please
Pandora turns into a lawless land with
bandits and gangs fighting for control
[Music]
for vault hunters arrive on Pandora in
search of the vault
not long after bumbling around the town
of Firestone the vault hunters find an
AI image of a woman called guardian
angel guardian angel instructs the
hunters to follow an over-enthusiastic
robot called claptrap after a series of
fights with local bandit leaders they
eventually get contacted by Patricia
tennis dolls archaeologists that was on
the planet before they flit she decided
to stay behind tennis had learned a
great number of things about the vault
she said the vault can only be opened
every two hundred years and that the
next opening was fast approaching but
also three more artifacts were required
to complete the vault key the vault
hunters get to work finding the
fragments but at the same time the
Crimson still is actively in search of
the key pieces to the vault hunters
secure the second and third pieces
following tennis instructions but the
final piece turns out not to exist the
commander of the Crimson
and forms the vault hunters that there
are only three parts to the key and the
tennis had betrayed them
the hunters find the vault and attempt
to stop the commander in the Crimson
Lance from opening it up but they were
too late when the vault opens a giant
creature called the destroyer secures
the commander and quickly wipes out the
Crimson Lance it turns out the ancient
aliens were using the vultures of prison
to hold this creature and stop it from
devouring the universe regardless the
vault hunters eventually killed the
destroyer the vault has been resealed
for another 200 years oddly enough the
guardian angel then admits to knowing
about this all along and that she has
been broadcasting to the vault hunters
from a satellite orbiting Pandora the
next game in the story is Borderlands
the pre-sequel this isn't the next game
that was released that was Borderlands 2
but after that came Borderlands the
pre-sequel which in game is based
between Borderlands 1 and 2 olam just
carry on to the story the opening scene
starts with a character called Athena
who was an ex Atlas assassin she has
been captured and has been interrogated
by Lilith and two of the vault hunters
sometime after the events of Borderlands
2
Athena goes on to tell the story of what
happened after she left the Crimson
Lance which was the time just after the
Borderlands 1 story yep it's a little
confusing but keep with me after the
vault on Pandora was opened Athena was
approached by a Hyperion programmer
named Jack to find another vault
Athena joins up with some vault hunters
and collect trap and take a ship to the
Hyperion moon base
Helios on the way there ambushed by the
Lost Legion an army of former Dahl
soldiers led by colonel czar padam czar
Pitt on the scene what's inside the
vault and decides that no human should
ever know about it so her in the Legion
defend the vault the vault hunters fight
off the ambushes and end up crash
landing into the moon base after meeting
up with Jack they decide to use the
defense system but find out that there's
a jamming signal coming from Pandora's
moon Elpis before they can escape
Colonels upper Don and a Lost Legion
turned up for this crazy alien dude or
dudette
I really shouldn't be assuming gender at
this point Jack manages to fire Athena
down to the planet while he fights off
the Lost Legion on his own Jack
instructs Athena to find someone called
moxie and she helps them find the origin
of the jamming signal
but while this is happening Sarpedon
activates hailey else's primary weapon
the eye of Helios which finds a huge
laser onto the surface of the Moon at
this point Jack thinks would be a really
cool idea to build a robot army and once
he does he decides to travel to Helios
with the vault hunters and defeat
Sarpedon and lost legion moxie and the
vault hunters proceed to reboot the eye
of Helios which happens to be the eye of
the destroyer that we saw in Borderlands
1 it's then that moxie reveals her true
intentions for helping Jack to destroy
the eye and prevent Jack from gaining
ultimate power Jack and the vault
hunters travel back to helpers where
they find the vault has already been
opened after defeating the vault
Guardians Jack enters the vault but
inside there's nothing of value the only
thing in there is a mysterious artifact
floating in mid-air when Jack attempts
to open up his throne into a projected
vision of the warrior being awoken while
cackling in a manic and disturbing
fashion Jack's vision is interrupted by
Lilith who faces him and full-on
Superman punches the artifact straighter
to Jack sitting his face on fire Jack
who's gone crazy from Lillis attack and
the vision that he witnessed to his
vengeance on not just her but all
bandits on Pandora
Athena realizes there's a little bit too
much crazy going on object to work for
him and leaves in the closing scene we
see Jack strangling a CEO he then
announces to a woman on the intercom
that he is now the new head of Hyperion
and tells her that he's to be called by
his new name handsome Jack five years
have passed since the events of
Borderlands 1 handsome Jack put out a
message to encourage vault hunters to
come to Pandora in search of iridium
tech but as the vault hunters make their
way across the planet they find that
this was all just a front for handsome
Jack's plan of killing all vault hunters
the transport there aboard is blown up
leaving the hunters for dead and this is
where they find the last Hyperion
claptrap robot the guardian angel gets
into contact with vault hunters and
instructs them to accompany claptrap to
the city of sanctuary and to join the
Crimson Raiders for an anti Hyperion
resistance movement in order to defeat
him some Jack they learn of a vault key
that has been transported aboard a
Hyperion train the vault hunters
derailed the Train but instead of
finding a key they find will help a
Hyperion cyborg Wilhelm is defeated and
the hunters recovers Power Core
of which is discussed as the best power
source for sanctuary shields but the
power cord turns out to be a trap from
handsome Jack the guardian angel who
turns out to be working for Jack ends up
lowering the city shields leaving it
open for attack from the Hyperion moon
satellite Lilith save century which was
originally a huge spacecraft by
activating its engines and teleporting
it away guardian angel ding gets in
contact with the hunters again she
apologizes but explains the jacks
holding her against her will as we know
from Borderlands 1 the vault key can
only be charged every two hundred years
but jack has figured out how to use the
guardian angel to charge the vault key
and speeding up the process guardian
angel also informs the hunters that the
Volk is being kept with her in a
Hyperion facility after giving
information around the facility's
defenses she requests that they hurry
but don't bring Lilith II
of course they ignore this request the
vault hunters assault the Hyperion
compound and meet angel who is not only
a real person but a siren and handsome
Jack's daughter she requests to be
killed in order to stop her father from
charging the key and opening up the
vault but when they finally agreed to do
this handsome Jack sins and waves of
security forces in order to stop them
but ultimately Lilith and the vault
hunters successfully kill angel the
enraged handsome Jack teleports him and
captures Lilith whom he forces to resume
the charging of the vault key in angels
stead as she's also a siren and
ultimately why angel didn't want her to
come along nice when Lilith Lilith
manages to teleport the vault hunters
out of the facility of back to sanctuary
they learn of the location of the second
vault and try to beat handsome Jack by
getting there first they were too late
Jack opens the vault and summons the
warrior eventually after a long fight to
the hunters defeat the warrior and
handsome jack Lilith attempts to destroy
the vault key however she accidentally
activates a secret information bank
containing a huge map of the galaxy with
several vaults marked on it
and here's when we go back to the
previous game that was released after
Borderlands 2 at the end of Borderlands
the pre-sequel having finished listening
to Athena's story lilith orders the
crimson raiders to executors however as
they open fire on Athena is saved for
the alien warrior who we first saw in
Hayley us with Colonels after than that
day who turns out is one of the ancient
legendary yridians who created the
vaults in the first place
the yridian warns the vault hunters on
an imminent war and that they would need
all of the vault hunters they can get
and here is where were likely to see
Borderlands 3 coming this was just a
quick run-through of the story up until
now there are a bunch of unique
entertaining characters and spin-offs
from the main story that wasn't able to
cover due to the original intention of
this video otherwise this could have
gone on for hours maybe I could look
into these later but if this was the
first game in the series that you've
decided to play you should now have the
general gist of what's going on in this
crazy universe interested in seeing more
Borderlands law let me know below I look
forward to seeing what they have in
store for us in the next game in the
series Borderlands 3 due to be released
in September this year Cheers
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]